this cemetery is located in Turkey but
has only Christian graves the names are
polish
among those buried here outside Istanbul
are the ancestors of Antonia Hoda many
poles fled what was then Tsarist Russia
in the 19th century and were welcomed by
the Sultan ruling the Ottoman Empire for
minor these are the grains of my
forefathers I'm fourth generation my
great-grandfather was born in Poland in
1820 and came here as a prisoner during
the Crimean War in 1848 but our village
was founded earlier in 1842 that's his
wife's grave there fro some graves
document the historical legacy of ethnic
poles who rose through the ranks
fighting for the Turkish Sultan's Armed
Forces
welcome to Paula Nez koi which in
Turkish means polish village it's polish
name is a damn pool named after its
founder the 170 year Polish heritage is
alive and well here there's a church
half-timbered houses orchards not so
long ago people also used to keep pigs
here
polonez koi is located 20 kilometers
east of Istanbul on the asian side of
the city while expanding Istanbul
threatens to engulf the village at some
point for the time being it remains a
popular escape from the hubbub of the
city its countless restaurants and guest
houses do great business Antoni de joder
runs a restaurant with his wife when
they were younger the two attended a
French boarding school in Istanbul today
some of their school friends from back
then are visiting we asked if Ana de
Hoda would have considered marrying a
Turkish man it's true that's difficult
that would require both sides being very
tolerant outside vision here we're well
integrated here but not assimilated we
have our own church our own cemetery and
our own customs the traditions include
Polish cuisine next door is a cafe run
by Agnes model in ska that serves
pancakes with blueberries from Poland
Agnes now lives in Warsaw but she spends
her summers in her home village in
Turkey I miss my friends and Warsaw when
I'm here but that isn't where I'm from I
was born and raised here it's here that
my parents and many relatives to live
the residents of polonez coy are Turkish
nationals their children go to Turkish
schools many ethnic poles here have set
up thriving businesses and between them
now employ several hundred of their
Muslim compatriots and they now also
have their own mosque
Monastery movie somebody was it's
Ramadan now and the Christians come to
celebrate the breaking of the fast with
us and we go to the polish festivities
our two cultures get along well when 77
year old on Tony de Hoda was a young boy
the poles had little contact with Turks
they were largely isolated here a local
history museum addresses the hardships
faced in the old days they spent their
winters cut off from the outside world
but there was never a dull moment as
senior residents recall used to be my
father's library when we were young we
would read books there in the evening
the church holds Catholic services for
the local community the Polish speaking
priest comes here once a month from
Istanbul in the summer when a lot of
residents slide to Poland to visit
family the congregation shrinks to a
handful the Polish consul general also
attends sermons here regularly his
government in Warsaw provides financial
support for polonez Khoi the younger
generation do not speak fluent polish
however and many end up leaving the
small community it remains to be seen
whether the next four generations will
remain loyal to this Polish home away
from home